was ist als alter du [ __ ] lasst
das doch einfach mit deiner scheiße du
schwerer kopf etwas glauben jetzt
willkommen beim neuen video wie es
wahrscheinlich schon erkannt hat ich bin
heute draußen ich brauche schon bin raus
gang und ich dachte warum ist das so
wahr mir ehrlich es ist so fucking warm
ich wollte mich gerade in die sonne
setzen ging nicht viel zu warm jetzt
sitze ich hier im schatten und hab mir
gedacht heute habe ich mir mal wieder
was ganz spezielles besonderes für euch
überlegt ich muss mich ja irgendwie es
ist voll shift stehe das irgendwie
schief das einzig geil ist so der winzer
es ist wenigstens ein bisschen windig
und das regt mich grad auf dies egal
auf jeden fall was hab ich mir überlegt
für heute habe ich mir ein paar
kommentare ausgesuchte direkt an der
grenze liegen sind aber auch ein
bisschen unterhaltsam natürlich so dass
sind heftig beleidigende kommentare
gegen mich die vor allem jetzt im
letzten drei vier fünf tagen nevada mal
zwei drei tagen auf mich zugekommen sind
selber schuld alex du bist einfach dumm
viel spaß ein bisschen vielleicht ich
würde sagen wir widmen uns einfach mal
diesen kommentaren und gehen ein
bisschen darauf ein
ich hoffe ihr habt spaß dran und wenn
ich jetzt demnächst im sommer öfter mal
draußen drehen soll
dann schreibt einfach mal in die
kommentare oder last schnellen nach oben
da dann sehe ich das hier
gut und dann fangen wir mal an und zwar
kommt der erste kommentar von katharina
und sie schreibt wie wir ist irgendwie
immer unsympathischer klar das ist
einfach konstruktive kritik nichts
beleidigendes das beleidigende kommt
dann gleich er ist auf jeden fall was
ich dazu sagen kann katharina ist okay
es ist deine meinung ist klar aber es
ist auch logisch dass ich ein mensch
wenn du mich jetzt zum beispiel schon
ein halbes jahr guckst man verändert
sich und auch vielleicht der content
verändert sich ein bisschen ich habe
früher viel junges mädchen themen
gemacht das wird jetzt auch wieder
kommen im sommer ich hab da einfach
keine lust mehr zugab tut mir leid
und vielleicht werde ich deswegen deiner
meinung nach immer unsympathischer der
kommentar hat vielleicht auf 140 likes
gut ich kann da nichts für ich ich mache
einfach das worauf ich lust habe und das
gefällt vielen manchen gefällt
vielleicht nicht so wie dir zum beispiel
und auch noch 140 anderen aber ich bin
mir sicher das ein oder andere video was
hinzukommt wirst du auch wieder ganz
toll finden hoffe ich und wenn ich dann
ist es leider so tut mir leid das ist
gehört dazu man guckt youtuber
vielleicht nicht sein leben lang sondern
nur ein halbes jahr oder drei monate und
danach sagt man der ist scheiße geworden
das ist ganz normal
tut mir leid das ist bei mir auch so ich
gucke auch manche youtuber gerne die ich
in zwei monaten nicht mehr gerne kugel
ach so und jetzt kommen wir zu den
beleidigenden wertung der kommentar ist
wirklich auch sehr konstruktive kritik
und zwar schreibt john smith schrieb die
pasta alter du [ __ ] lasst doch was
als erhalter befruchten lassen das doch
einfach mit deiner scheiße schwerer kopf
ich weiß zwar nicht welche hoffe du
meinst meine haare sind wieder
vielleicht war das unter dem video wo
ich lange heirate noch auf jeden fall ja
ich mache meine haare bald wieder etwas
länger dann werden hier oben lässt auch
scheißegal
sie hat dann sehen und danke für diesen
kommentar ach so sperber kopf weil an
einer sperre mir immer gut will ich gar
nicht weiter darauf eingehen
danke für den kommentar hat mich sehr
gefreut hab' ich auch nicht nächster
könnte und zwar kann das machen youtuber
wenn ihnen nichts mehr einfällt fällt
wie bringt ja paar klicks ganz ehrlich
so das war vielleicht dumm habe ich ja
gestern schon im video gesagt dieses
pack dingsbums aber so viel hat sie das
jetzt auch nicht gebracht keine angst
ich habe dadurch vielleicht 800
abonnenten gemacht ist
okay aber es ist jetzt auch nicht die
welt es tut mir noch mal leid aber mir
fällt sehr viel ein ich habe in meinem
ablaufplan ich habe immer so einen
schönen upload plan
da ist nur für die nächsten drei wochen
genug drin deswegen keine angst und ich
bin eigentlich ein relativ manchmal bin
ich kreativ manchmal überhaupt nicht
weswegen ich bin mir sicher es kommen
coole videos wie gesagt dass mit diesem
brief scheiße sich nämlich so an muss
ich glaube ich jetzt nicht noch oft
genug sagen und danke für deinen
kommentar ist auch egal wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten kommentar 121
likes ein wort was in der heutigen
gesellschaft vor allem mit dem aufkommen
der neuen jugend eine ganz andere ganz
neue bedeutung gewinnt als ich 13 14 war
das wirklich noch ein richtig großes
wort und heute jeder der irgendetwas
falsches macht ist einfach ein leute
schild mal überlegt wo hallo also ich
will jetzt auf jeden fall nicht sagen
dass 13 oder 14 jährige zuschauer von
mir dieses wort falsch benutzen das ist
ja auf den ganz kleinen teil von euch
nur jetzt bezogen und zwar als ich 314
war dieses wort wirklich krass und ihr
müsst überlegen wo das herkommen touren
so das ist ja schon ziemlich beleidigend
ehrlich und ich finde niemand auf der
ganzen welt hat es verdient außer
vielleicht ein paar menschen die
irgendwie umgebracht haben
als sowas betitelt zu werden und auch
vor allem auf youtube upgrade ist
einfach überall ein wurden sohn das
verstehe ich einfach überhaupt nicht ich
meinen der macht das was ihm spaß macht
klar dass eine andere ist vielleicht
etwas bedenklich
trotzdem bei mir es auch vieles
bedenklich aber es gibt doch keinen
menschen der welt das recht jemanden als
[ __ ] zu betiteln
ganz ehrlich dass das finde ich richtig
scheiße so manche sachen von mir waren
auch scheiß aber ich würde niemals
irgendwen von euch oder sonst wen der
mich so beleidigt so zurück beleidigen
das finde ich schade
aber wenn sich halt die gesellschaft ein
bisschen so verändert ist es so kann ich
auch keinen einfluss darauf nehmen weiß
ich selber wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten kommentar und zwar schreibt
caspar irgendwas dicker alex du lügner
verkauft ein arzt missgeburt weil sonst
gehst du noch so hoch mit den dislike
süchtiger hoch ganz ehrlich soll ich
darauf jetzt eigentlich oder nicht ist
ist sogar illegal sein youtube account
zu verkaufen das darf man gar nicht wie
gesagt schild ein leben ich mache nur
das was mir spaß macht und wenn es dir
nicht gefällt
guck dir nicht an immer diese
rechtschreibung auch ich verstehe nicht
wie man so eine recht
eltern haben kann das ist für mich
unverständlich man man kann doch so was
nicht mit guten bedenken abschicken du
kannst du was du nicht irgendwie
kommentieren mit deinem vor und
nachnamen der dabei steht alter ok
nächster kommentar kommt von jonathan er
schreibt ich mag ihn mittlerweile gar
nicht mehr ist jetzt schon ein richtiger
08 15 youtube deutschland youtuber vor
sechs monaten und 250.000 autos weniger
war das ganze noch anderes als auch noch
mal an dich
es tut mir leid dass ich mich genauso
wie jeder andere mensch verändert dass
ich nicht immer meinen gleichen content
weiter führe wenn es mir keinen spaß
gemacht man mich halt anderen konnten
aber das was ich früher gemacht habe
wird es jetzt in zukunft auch weiterhin
geben habe ich lust zu schild euer leben
tut mir leid wenn ich dem einen oder
anderen ein bisschen unsympathisch rüber
komme finde ich richtig gemein nein
alles gut kann ich voll mit umgehen ich
glaube da war noch ein lieber kommentar
bei denen ich nicht so ganz verstanden
habe ach du meine güte ist so süß dieses
leck 134 gleicht also der kommentar war
nicht auf mich bezogen sondern auf meine
freundin
na gut wenigstens gibt's noch eine
person auf seinem youtube-channel ihr
mögt danke
spaß beiseite ich weiß dass ganz viele
von euch mich noch genau so mögen wie
früher das freut mich persönlich sehr
dankeschön für euren support vor allem
letzter zeit merke ich dass wir wachsen
finde ich super geil freut mich und
nochmal auf die ganzen leute die
schreiben ich bin clique heute jeder
youtuber es gibt kein youtuber in ganz
es gibt kein youtube auf der ganzen welt
der nicht gerne seine videos in der
öffentlichkeit verbreiten möchte dieses
wort klingt ergibt für mich überhaupt
keinen sinn das existiert für mich gar
nicht das ist einfach youtube wird doch
mittlerweile auch als job angesehen und
warum soll man nicht seine videos sie
waren mit leidenschaft produziert auch
der öffentlichkeit bestmöglich verkaufen
sag ich mal
deswegen gilt bitte da was das angeht
euer leben
ihr schaut doch alle gerne youtube sonst
würde ich jeden tag nicht auf dieser
plattform befinden manchmal kann ich das
sogar vielleicht verstehen wenn es bei
dem einen oder anderen zuschauer
vielleicht an einem tag in der schule
nicht so gut lief und man das dann
irgendwie auf youtube oder auf einen
bestimmten youtuber überträgt aber leute
schild bitte alle euer leben es ist nur
youtube
es soll eigentlich nur eine
unterhaltsame plattform sein das ist
kein ort um irgendwen grundlos zu
beleidigen
sei es jetzt der youtuber der der
youtuber sei es auch bei manchen
kommentaren jetzt ich in den letzten
zwei tagen ist okay mein gott das war's
mit dem video
wenn ihr das auch so sieht dann schreibt
man die kommentare oder lassen doch nach
oben da relativ video gefallen hat das
netz schon damals ein abonniert nicht
vergessen abonnieren nicht vergessen
aber ich vergesse nichts dazu verpassen
ich hoffe dadurch gefallen ja wir sehen
uns sonntag wieder denke ich oder
vielleicht auch schon morgen keine
ahnung schaut einfach rein rein hieß